pour les collèges ce sont environ 5000
élèves qui vont retourner en classe au
mois de juin une rentrée très
progressive et sur la base du
volontariat qui concerne d'abord les
sixièmes et les cinquièmes prendre pour
cent des effectifs devraient à terme
revenir dans les établissements des
chiffres communiqués par le rectorat des
yvelines
est ce un rythme de 4 à 5 jours de
classe dans le mois ce sont 116 collège
des yvelines qui vont donc rouvert leurs
portes avec un accueil à partir de jeudi
et pour parler de ce sujet avec nous ou
fabien le duigou bonsoir secrétaire
adjoint du snes fsu des yvelines a le
snes fsu premier syndicat des
enseignants du second degré vous est
également professeur de sos a déjà sur
cette réouverture qui a été annoncée la
semaine dernière par le gouvernement il
était nécessaire pour les collégiens
pour ces lycéens aussi professionnel de
prévoir ce retour en classe pour ce mois
de juin bon on s'y attendait un petit
peu professionnel et général avaient
déjà que vous l'avez dit ça sera un nom
de l'unité effectivement deux demi
journées pour les élèves ont fabriqué
des lèvres puisque c'est pour baser sur
le sur le vent arrière
mais si on regarde un petit peu ce qui
se passe dans le premier degré depuis
wallner à l'ouverture des écoles du
premier degré si effectivement le mini
jeu peut se targuer de une proportion
d'établissements du premier degré écoles
tous les degrés assez importante à qui
on a ouvert
quand on regarde la proportion d'élèves
qui ont effectivement été accueilli dans
ses élèves dans ces états sont ces
écoles là les chiffres beaucoup plus
cher souvent c'est les assauts contre la
gardelle doigts de la main et on
remarque aussi que souvent c'est dans
les zones prioritaires raid raid plus
que les élèves en fait rentrer moins que
le mois que dans les cours on peut donc
craindre
je pensais que les élèves qui ont le
plus grand risque de décrochage en lycée
professionnel
on peut craindre que finalement le
nombre d'élèves font d'accueil pour
accueillir en dispose ne soit pas très
élevé ça c'est la crainte qu'on a
négligé alors l'une des raisons de la
réouverture en tout cas c'est l'une des
raisons n'ont cessé de faire revenir
aussi dans les établissements ses élèves
décrocheurs on les estime à environ 15 %
dans le département st
nomen qui a été observée du côté des
enseignants ces élèves décrocheurs
oui parce qu'on fur et à mesure que les
l'école à distante royer effectivement
des élèves qui voient là lors des
premières semaines et réactif étaient
présents sur des zones habitées dans les
classes virtuelles etc
et puis au fur et à mesure va évidemment
le leur nombre dépassait donc oui c'est
pas étonnant
et effectivement si l'objectif affiché
ses deux en priorité d'accueillir ces
élèves décrocheurs
alors on sait pas qu'il y avait de la
baguette magique au fait pour les faire
revenir puisque c'est basé sur le
volontariat chez des élèves qui ont déjà
un pied hors de l'école ont pris leurs
distances cathy david de l'école depuis
cette agression ou de lait on sait pas
comment on va on va les carolos et on
peut aussi se poser la question fabien
le vgoh si on prend le cas des collèges
les enfants prioritaires a priori rond
en classe 4 fois par semaine mais pour
les autres on parle plutôt de revenir
pour 4 à 5 jours de classe dans le mois
de juin est ce que il était utile de
reprendre pour seulement cinq jours de
classe dans un mois forcément les
questions qui se posent d'un point de
vue purement pédagogique non sans doute
qu'il ya pas beaucoup d'intérêt
par contre ça peut être aussi un moyen
de les raccrocher de faire un petit
bilan avec le fatah du confinement pense
qu'il ya des choses que les élèves rares
besoin de verbaliser donc c'est pas
forcément inutile mais c'est sûr que
d'un point de vue pédagogique doit par
contre
d'autant plus que dans certains
établissements ce qui a été décidé en
commun des nations c'est que les élèves
ont quelquefois accueilli les parents
les professeurs ont quelquefois
accueillir des élèves qui n'allait pas
en faire soit parce qu'ils ne
connaissent pas donc effectivement le
l'intérêt pédagogique pour ces élèves
qui vont venir afin de limiter demi
journée et ça veut dire oui au niveau
des programmes pas de pas de nouveaux
points abordés ça va être un travail sur
les acquis voulait dit peut-être aussi
verbaliser sur la période qui vient de
se dérouler cette de confinement et de
début de déconfinement nuit va pas je ne
vois pas comment quelques demi journées
comme ça on pourrait finir le programme
le tenter de compléter le programme
notamment la vie oui le
je peux vous faire les enseignants c'est
effectivement des révisions retravailler
certaines méthodologies qui ont été vus
au cours de l'année effectivement
discuté dans mon établissement par
exemple qui à la fois un lycée
professionnel mais aussi jarret
technologies on a prévu d'accueillir sur
une demi-journée les tous les élèves
copies de bac cgra théologie pour
discuter avec eux quand on écoute bien
ce qu'a dit mr lycée général et
technologique il proposait une chose
c'était des entretiens pédagogique je
vais vous poser la question est ce que
vous trouvez cette idée cohérente on
alors on sait que les lycéens du
professionnel c'est un retour en classe
qui est prévu mais pour ces lycéens
effectivement du général on parle plutôt
d'entretiens personnalisés sur
rendez-vous pour pour des questions
pédagogiques des entretiens pédagogique
est ce que c'est cohérent de la part du
gouvernement de proposer un tel plan un
autre changement pas du tout ce que les
élèves ont besoin là c'est de vous
trouver du collectif de revoir leurs
camarades leurs professeurs ils pas du
tout à l'entretien individuel il va
ressembler au mieux à un rendez vous
chez le psy pour savoir comment s'est
passée de confinement ou au pire un
interrogatoire délais d'un pourquoi tu
t'es pas connectés et c'est donc je sais
pas du tout la solution
d'ailleurs quand il a commencé a été
faite jeudi
on était touché au téléphone en train de
te dire de quoi il parle qu'est ce que
c'est que ce dispositif qui a été a été
inventée jusque là pour le mois de juin
et donc quand on écoute de mémoire
c'était dans la phase de questions
réponses avec la presse
et juste après l'intervention des
premiers disques d'unité nationale il ya
dix ailleurs que je vous pouvez très
bien transformer c'est assez autre chat
du duel en activité en deux groupes
donc en fait ni individuelles nippes et
dany veut pédagogique des potentiels
m'en faire faire défaire des activités
court bref sommes quand même que la
confusion régnait sur ces annonces
concernant le lycée général
on a compris les réserves que vous
émettez sur ce sujet un dernier point
sur le calendrier de cette rentrée
aujourd'hui c'était plutôt une journée
de prérentrée pour les pour les
enseignants le retour en classe va se
faire à partir de jeudi
oui alors là ils ont les ils ont donné
beaucoup de liberté effectivement une bo
locales aux chefs d'établissement
effectivement pas retouché déplaire
entrer dans des réunions et puis les
élèves effectivement soit jeudi soit
même vers semaine prochaine fodé
d'établissement qu'il y avait un peu de
temps on leur donnait un petit peu
d'être effectivement d'abord on prépare
cette reprise donc notamment dans les
collèges et lycées pros ne serait ce que
pour vérifier que les protocoles
sanitaires sont bien mis en place former
informer les personnes essaient juste de
barrières touche à tout je fais chauffer
la colle
il rappelle notamment pour terminer
s'entretient avec les masques 1 seront
obligatoires pour ces élèves de collèges
et de lycées professionnels merci fabien
le duigou d'avoir été avec nous les
professeurs dans l'es16 dans les
yvelines secrétaire adjoint du snes fsu
des yvelines bonne rentrée à vous donc